I'm not allowed to do takeout I'm not
allowed to go out to a restaurant I'm
going to be making my food
I am a bad cook I am a lazy person I
don't have the time the patience to cook
I really need to learn to cook a little
because you know going out to
restaurants is wasting a lot of money my
goal is to find one meal that is easy to
do that I can do every week I realized I
made a mistake in that I froze the
chicken and it really needs to be
defrosted so we are going to have some
issues with that timing things so that
they end up at the same time is
difficult well I'm really impressed with
restaurants pulled out the slow cooker
and just put all the ingredients in
there so tonight when I'm eating it's a
lot watch okay that's the last corn on
the cob I had I bought that I didn't
make it and that is the chicken that was
slow-cooked that I made up last night
there's a feeling of accomplishment when
you finish cooking a dish and it's
edible but for me it didn't happen that
often I made some pretty bad meals I
like fruit but I heard it's like healthy
candy so try not to get too much so
right now I'm making a peach and
blueberry smoothie this isn't a recipe
this is a made-up recipe I don't know
the peaches were the right decision they
had a an incident okay so I'm making a
chicken and broccoli casserole
I left the plastic cover on my casserole
dish and cooked it for about an hour I'm
just I'm just such an idiot I'm such an
idiot oh my god oh my god
it's so embarrassing because you know I
feel like 10 year olds know you don't
put plastic in the oven I know you don't
poo plastic in the oven but I put
plastic in me up the fumes from the
burnt plastic we were inhaling them and
we were poisoning ourselves so we went
outside it's not worth it
cooking's not worth it it really hurt my
ego to learn that I was that bad at
cooking right now I'm being very brave
and I'm making my pasta dish that's
right I'm stepping it up I'm gonna eat
healthy and also I'm gonna eat food I
cook cuz that's gonna be a big step for
me my goal is to find one meal that is
easy to do that I can do every week
pasta apasa Christmas pasta it's good I
would eat it just like I would eat every
pasta I learned that I mean very simple
recipes I learned that I should follow
recipes because some people are born to
cook and others are not and I am NOT